Jetpacks. Real-life Iron Man jet packs.
Oh my god!! Every single person who has flown today has not hovered yet...
I will hover. I will hover.
I have always been in love with flying, the dream of flying through the sky and as a kid
I wanted to be a fighter pilot. As an adult I got into racing drones,
'cause when this thing is going through the air from my perspective
It actually looks like I am the one flying doing flips diving down buildings doing all kinds of crazy acrobatics
But this is still a proxy for actual flight. My body is still tethered to the earth
But what if I could fly?
So we're here in Camarillo at the air 7 hangar because we're looking at an actual jetpack
This is Richard Browning who spent the last several years developing and inventing the jet suit
He's got a whole TED talk talking about that process
I got invited by a man named Sam who's an engineer for this company called Gravity, and Gravity is making jetpacks
Real-life Iron Man jetpacks.
"I made it in a cave with a pile of scraps!"
You may have seen these jetpacks before on Instagram
The videos have been blown up Adam Savage even made a whole Iron Man video with the jetpack coming into today
I didn't know what to expect. I was like, oh, I'll get to see it
I'll get to hang out. And then they're like, oh, so you wanna learn how to fly? It was like
I mean I can actually put the suit on and try to fly?
That's pretty freakin' sweet man, like the fact that that exists at all
Like we always dreamed about jetpacks as a kid, you know
It's like someday we'll all have jetpacks and fly around because it's the future. Well the future's now
I have no idea how hard it's gonna be to learn how to fly. Sam, how do you think you're doing?
It's like - it's like once you do it once you will not want to get off
It's just inexplicably like a strange sensation having so much power. I have confidence
I'm gonna nail this first take first try. However, I think the reality is that it's not gonna be that way. So we'll see
I'm gonna be here until I learn how to hover. That is my goal.
I will hover.
Let's go ahead and talk to Sam who's one of the engineers on this jetpack, and actually learn how this thing was built and how
it works. This is all 3D printed in nylon and aluminium here
It's 5 micro gas turbines that you put on your body two on each arm
And on the back is one larger entity you end up as kind of a tripod of thrust and you're just using your body
to redirect those engines and redistribute that thrust to allow you to move around
So if you imagine leaning on a table like that, that's as hard as it is. Yeah
I already know how to fly, I can do that.
- Exactly, you're done.
So is there like a throttle for each arm individually?
As you bring that in like that will increase the the throttle of the engines
But we always fly at full power
We'll bring that trigger into full power for your body weight and you'll be able to hold it out there like that and then only
when you vector those down, the throttle staying the same on all those engines,
will you then take off. It's throttle controlled by moving your arms around.
As fast as you can move your arms is as fast as you can change your thrust going downwards technically
I'll give you some ear defenders because it is extremely loud.
"My ears are bleeding" loud.
So when I first started it was at the stage of kind of a prototype
We're just experimenting with 3d printing some parts, but it was made from available parts that we assembled together
It's just about trying something as quickly as possible. Seeing if it works and then either ditching it or going with it.
It's cool with a project like this that it doesn't have like a formal purpose or exact application
So I want to try and make it look as close to a sci-fi movie as possible
And the next thing I'm working on at the moment actually is just for fun, is the visor that goes
*ket-chung* *whishhh!* Like that.
I guess Wren's out at the runway right now and they're gonna let him fly this jetpack suit thing and
you know, knowing Wren, he's pr-
- [Robotic voice] I am Jarvis.
Don't worry about that. It's just Jarvis.
He's an agile guy, but he puts himself into these situations where he's constantly
risking life and limb.
- [Robotic voice] I am Jarvis.
- Jarvis...
- [Robotic voice] Enjoy yourself, sir.
I thought it would be good to take this opportunity before anything happens and just go through and update his just-in-case.
- [Off-camera] His what?
- His just-in-case.
- [Robotic voice] I am Jarvis.
Jarvis, stop.
What's a just-in-case?
Have I not talked to you about this? This part of the employee handbook, the one I gave out.
I have just-in-case websites for everyone in the studio.
- Just in case what?
- [Robotic voice] I am Jarvis.
Just in case what?
Just in case you die.
That's so f****d up. So anyway using today's sponsor Squarespace
I made a just in case you die website for everybody and I thought it'd be a good chance to update Wren's!
Everyone will be able to go to this website and find out how, right, find out
how here there's a button: Wren, you were a really nice person. You always had a smile on your face.
Billy
my Billy Boy
You always wanted to fly so high.
- He did love hotdogs.
- He loved hotdogs. I mean, that would be a great one
So the first thing that Squarespace does that I really like is a thing called simultaneous
posting. We can post one time on the website and it will
automatically format and post to his Twitter and Facebook profiles. Now, the only thing I have to do is get his password.
I told you about the just-in-case thing that I was updating for Wren, right?
- Yeah, just in case. Yeah
Yeah, just in case, you know, I need his Twitter password. Do you have it?
Wren's Twitter password?
- Yeah.
- Um, I don't think so...
The next thing that we can do if Ren has an ultimate oopsie is I figured we could have a podcast in his memory using
Squarespace's audio box tool we'll be able to host the audio from that podcast onto our Squarespace website and have it automatically
go out as an RSS feed to wherever we want it to go.
I wanted to know if you guys could do the podcast with me.
Okay, I would be honored.
Just in case!
I am curious to see my just-in-case.
Basically every Monday I go in and I update them just based on what I know people
are working on that week?
Just in case!
Jarvis! Open! Open the mask. Jarvis!
A third cool thing about Squarespace is that it allows you to have multiple contributors to a website.
So all you do is go under your management tools and you can add new people that have different types of access to your site
It's a really helpful tool
Yo Dean!
Hey man! I almost had to hit publish on you when you fell off your one-wheel the other day, didn't I?
Yeah, I saw my life flash before my eyes.
Yeah, I know. That just in case, that's why we build them, right?
- Yeah.
- Do you think that just in case if I die, that you could post on Wren's site and let everyone know?
Using multiple contributors I could do that.
Okay. So anyway
if you guys are interested in head on over to squarespace.com/corridorcrew
and you'll get 10% off the purchase of your first website or domain.
Remember, just in case: use Squarespace!
Some people are having some trouble actually learning how to fly. It's taking them quite a bit of effort
You have two minutes to kind of just like bounce around and kind of like learn how it affects you
Now I'm having to go at the end of the line here because the guys who are flying right now are actually paying to fly.
So that guy was the vice president of Oculus...
Every single person who has flown today has not hovered yet. Not a single person is hovered. It's making me a little concerned.
I like to think that I have a good sense of balance and athleticism but there's no reason to say that these guys don't.
Logically I understand that I have to kind of make myself a tripod.
Lock my arms any amount forward that's gonna make me do that. I have to make sure that I'm like
very steady, and it's gonna be squishy, and I just kind of, kind of learn how it pushes me around before
I actually get to a point where I go up.
I'm scrapping any sort of expectation that I'll actually be able to take off on my first try. That's just not gonna happen.
I say that now. I'm obviously totally gonna try to take off a little bit on my first try but we'll see I might totally
Ruin it. I don't know
At a certain point I was like I'm not gonna get to fly.
All right, we got two more clients and then you'll be the last flight of the day. I was like, I'm gonna get to fly
It's a special
heat-resistant material, this is what we like you to wear underneath just to protect your skin.
All right, done.
I already know how to fly it. I'll just snip the cable and fly away.
- You psyched?
- I'm so psyched!
- Yeah!!
Gimme everything you got.
Dude, you lift these things up, and you're gonna go backwards. One arm goes like this:
So just kind of like, aim them, kind of like this, feel it out
As Richard said it's like oddly calm, but, like crazy.
- So you ready?
- Oh my God, yes.
Stay relaxed, that's the key.
I'm like going through an Ironman suit up sequence right now
- So, you ready?
- These are heavy.
Okay, if you head off to the [inaudible]...
... and if you now lean over forwards, it's gonna help the rear engine start.
Just bend over as much as you can.
Nice job, Wren!
Good job, dude!
Dude, that was [bleep] amazing.
Dude, I could feel - I could just, like I'm on a little squishy cloud!
I felt like Goku man, it's like riding a Nimbus!
It felt like balancing on top of like a ball.
- But you're vectoring on that
first one, like you completely understood that, wait 'til it powers up out here, then bring it down.
You were super comfortable there.
That was the best first go. And his, just ability to maintain stability was like the best.
They're letting me try again because I actually came pretty close to hovering.
I knew you could hover.
You think so?
Yeah, I think so, maybe.
Now continue doing those jumps into the air with slightly more power
We'll start you slightly below what you just ended on
That was so good.
Very impressive.
Whoo!
Dude that felt so good! That felt great!
I was flying there for a moment!
You've now joined a very very small number of people who've managed to hover on their second go. Like, super impressive.
Ahhaha, my God!
My shoulders are exhausted now, though! Dude, it's all that beat sabre training that allowed me to do this at all
That was one of the most satisfying experiences of my life, to be completely honest. It's also slightly
disappointing, because I feel I can do so much better just with a little bit more practice.
But this is not one of those things that you can just,
buy at a store and practice on, so I feel very humbled to have even had this opportunity.
What's going on?
We for a little while have had these little, like, challenge coins. You know, it's kind of an American tradition
- Yeah.
- So you, you qualify
there is, there is a coin
there is the flight experience one. Now, pretty unusually and
ridiculously in two goes - usually, I mean you do really well if you get it in five or six, but you did it in two -
So there is a silver one
which is pretty special that is like, the light one. And now I'm going to tease you and show you the gold one
There is the gold one
which is the one that you get when you kind of free-flight so next time
Some day -
Well, not even some day
I think you were really good, so it won't be long before you get one of those.
- Thank you.
- So well done.
- Dude - guys, this has been great!
- Yeah, pleasure having you
Well done, well done.
Thank you. Oh my God, two coins in one go!
Take On Gravity is such a special company, You know, they're constantly improving the jet pack,
they're constantly going to these events to actually show off flying around. The best way for you to see what they're all up to is
to follow them on Instagram: Take On Gravity. And - and who knows, maybe we'll actually do something together again this year.
Absolutely consider subscribing
for maybe some of that in the future. I think we got
I think we got some, some cool stuff ahead of you. Especially this racing drone? Imagine if this thing shot Nerf darts.
subscribe to that
corririrririirdoor